[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
So you don't believe that Jesus is God,
right? He's a God. He's a God, but not
like not Yahweh, not Jehovah, not
Almighty. He's not.
I know the trinity, the word is in the
Bible. So the concept is
there is a father, there's a son, it's a
spirit. Yeah.
My thing is the concept comes from
derives from Catholicism. Nothing wrong
with that, right? There is something
wrong with that.
So what I wanted to talk to you about I
didn't ask you but what I wanted to talk
to you about was uh the Christ you
serve. The Christ you serve. The Christ
I serve. Yes. Yeah. Do you believe there
are multiple Christ? Do you believe we
just because everyone seems to know this
one Christ? Yeah. But we told in
scriptures there will be false Christ.
Yeah. Okay. So how do we distinguish?
How do we know which Christ is false?
Yeah. Because the one the the true
Christ told us who he is. He showed us
who he is and he told us what to look
out for and that he's going to come in a
particular way again. So if anyone says
there's the Christ or there's the Christ
or there he is in the mountains or there
he is in the in the desert, don't
believe him because I told you guys how
I'm coming. I told you guys who I am.
And if if you're saying that like for
example like Jesus told us that he is
one in essence with the father that he
is not just a god that in a lesser way
than the father is but that he's unhigh
with the father if there's anything
outside of that then that's falsehood
that's that's unbiblical okay um Matthew
7 21-23 we're all familiar with yeah
Matthew 7 7:21-23
very uh
Not everyone who says, right? Yeah. Not
everyone who says Lord, Lord will enter
the kingdom. Right. Uh but those who do
the will of my father, right? So if you
verse 23 says, uh let me just
anyone got it. 7:21. Oh, nice. Got that.
That's what I'm talking about.
All my all my faults. Not not Yeah. Not
everyone not everyone assist me Lord
Lord we will enter the kingdom of heaven
but the one that does the will of my
father in heaven on that day many will
come and say to me Lord Lord uh we have
we not prophesy in your name cast out
demons in your name um I will declare to
them I never knew you
workers of lawlessness you workers of
lawlessness I believe Christianity is
lawlessness yeah but you already you're
already you're already in lawlessness by
denying his deity. No, let's not. Let's
stay with this, right? This is what
we're This is what we started off with.
This is the Christ we're serving. So,
this is how we know which one we're
serving because the Christ of the Bible,
brother, Christ of the Bible. Before you
go into that, we got to talk about the
identity of of link. I will link it
because
this is very passionate with the Trinity
and all that, right? Yeah. I mean,
that's that's that's where that that's
where No, it starts with who Jesus is
and then we can talk about what Jesus
commands of us. If you if we're confused
on Yeah. If I I agree. But if we're if
we don't know who he is in the first
place, then knowing what he commands and
and requires of us, our doctrine will be
off. So, we got I agree. I mean, I was
going to bring you on to that, but um
Christ now you're saying he's uh he's
one in essence with the father. So, he's
agree. They want truth, right? One in
essence, not not in purpose, not but in
essence. They share the same divine
essence. Just whatever the father is,
the son is also. Me and my father are
one. I agree. Yes. But not but not in
purpose. But they're not they're
completely different. The father is
different from the son, right? He's
they're distinct persons, right? So they
can they communicate with each other.
However, this father and son, they share
the same essence. So the father is God.
The son is God also. The problem is all
over the scriptures, they're not equal.
But what trinity does is creates this
creates this equality with the son and
the father. For example, the son doesn't
know the last day. The father does. He
does. Yeah. John 6 John 16:30 says that
the son knows all things. No. Okay. Um
what was it? John 5
last day. John 7:16. Christ answered and
said, "My doctrine is not mine, but of
him that sent me." Um,
but of that day an hour no man knows no
man, nor the angels or my father only.
Mark 13:32 is actually right. But of
that day and hour knows no man. Yeah.
Not the angels in heaven, neither the
son. Yeah, it's declarative equal. Well,
it's declarative. He doesn't know they
can't be equal. I agree. But which is
why he does know this is talking about
declarative knowledge, not cognitive.
This is the last day. Well, like like
for example, the father just really
quick brother. So like when Paul says
when I came to you I decided to know
nothing except Jesus Christ and him
crucified. Does that mean that Paul
literally didn't know anything? This is
this is very specific. Well, it's the
same word. Very specific. It's the same
Greek word. Oh, he did. But this is
specific on the last day. I know. Do you
know when the after the resurrection?
Yeah. Yeah. And he said it's not for you
to know. It's not for you to know. Yeah.
He doesn't say I don't I don't know. to
himself to know, not him. Well, he said
no, he doesn't say that. He says what
the father has fixed by his own
authority. I didn't include himself.
Well, he says it's not for you to know.
This is the same as what I just read.
Okay. So, so explain this to me. I need
you to answer this. Wait, wait. Stop.
Stop. Slow down. I need you to answer
this. When Paul says that when I came to
you, I decided to know nothing. Same
word. Oh, he didn't that Jesus uses in
Mark 13:32. When he says, "I came to you
and decided to know nothing except Jesus
and him crucified." Does that mean that
Paul literally didn't know anything else
other than Jesus being crucified? Can't
align with that. I'm just asking, does
that mean he didn't know anything? He
doesn't. Huh? He doesn't. He doesn't
know anything else. Paul, there's two
specific topics we're dealing with here,
brother. So, does Paul not know his own
name? Does he not know that he's a Roman
citizen? I can because he uses the same
word. Okay. So there's multiple. What
about the false? Wait, wait, pause.
You're you're moving away. Does Paul not
know anything else? Yes, he does.
Exactly. So what does it mean? So what
does it mean when he says, "I decided to
know nothing except Jesus crucified."
What does that has to do with the
scripture? It has to do with Look, it
has to do with how you're using the word
no. And you're using it and saying when
Jesus says no one knows. Here's Wait,
let me let me tell you why I'm how it
connects. You said you came here to Mark
13:32 where Jesus says, "No one knows
the hour, nor the angels or the son, but
the father only." Right? But um but I'm
showing you that the Jesus or that Paul
uses the same word for himself when he
visits the Corinthians and says he
decided to know nothing except Jesus and
him crucified. Context. So do you see
the context is different? Context.
Context is different. Now okay talking
about here was very specific. So what
about the what about the context? Wait.
So do we agree? Okay. Do we agree that
the word can be declarative, not
cognitive? Yeah, I agree. Okay, good. So
what tells you in Mark 13:32 that it's
not declarative, but it's cognitive. So
now you've now made it subjective. No, I
haven't. It suits you. You have. I have
not. Let me tell you. Let me tell you
the wickedness of Trinity. I'll tell you
I'll tell you. No, tell me this. I know.
Listen, you're very skilled and I give
you that. I give you that.
Trinity, what's his heritage? Do you
know that's that's a different subject.
I mentioned Catholicism here and you
said it doesn't matter matters a lot.
Brother, you got to tell me what by what
biblical basis. Listen listen, you got
to tell me contextually why when Jesus
says no one knows, not the son or the
angels, that that is cognitive knowledge
and not declarative. So he has that's
why I'm saying it's subjective because
pick and choose when it means something
when it doesn't. No, the context tells
us there's two different scriptures that
say the same thing. And also in Acts, as
I mentioned, when he said only the
father knows, that's a different word. I
know, but it's still the same. And he
doesn't say only the father knows in
acts. Look, that the father has to
himself to Okay. He says that it's not
for you to know, right? The signs and
the season that the father has fixed for
his own authority. Yes. He has to
include himself there. He did not. He
doesn't have to. No, he doesn't. There
you go. That's my point. See, I don't
want to I don't want to want to get lost
in the point that I'm trying to make in
the in the false Jesus that you are
serving. Why? Why? Why doesn't he Why if
you're talking about inclusion, why
doesn't he include himself when he says,
"Wait, listen. Listen. I need you to
listen cuz notice we got from Mark
13:32, now we're an ass." But it's okay.
But I'm I'm on your point, bro. Let me
just bring it. No, but you're you're
you're talking about something else.
That's not about monologues about
something else. What's more important?
salvation, right? Oh my goodness.
Brother, you got to be able to stay
focused, man. Stay focused. I'm very
focused. Okay. Are we We're talking
about Acts. Your point was Jesus doesn't
include himself in when he says the
times and seasons that the father fixed
by his own authority. Okay. Let me go
with your logic. Okay. According to the
verse, does Jesus include himself when
he says it's not for you to know what
the father has fixed? Does he include
himself? No. No. Okay. So if he doesn't
include himself, can I reason then that
he's not part of the group that's not
supposed to know? That's what the
scripture says. No, it doesn't. It
doesn't. Nowhere does it say where does
Jesus include himself? Where does Jesus
say that? Multiple scriptures he is
severing himself away from the father.
Where does it talk about in knowledge?
Look
the father doesn't
serve the son. The son serves the
father. Where do you get where do you
get that from? You agree? No. The father
also serves the son. Serves the son.
Absolutely.
Jesus Jesus literally says, "I thank
you, Lord, that you always hear me." The
father does everything the son asks him
to do. What are you talking about? So,
wait, wait. So, this is what I don't
want to get to. Let me let me go to my
point and bring it home because you're
going to lose. Let me just bring it
home. I'm touching on everything you
say. Trinity. This is what this is this
is why I'm going about Trinity. Okay.
You don't serve the most high. Who's the
most high? Living in in trinity. Who's
the most high? Give you an example.
Do you celebrate Passover?
Who's the Most High? Celebrate Passover.
I do in In Christ. Yes. In Christ. He's
the He's the Passover. I don't mean
Easter. Passover. Yeah. You're You're
switching topics now again to Passover.
So, the Father has given us a
commandment. keep the Passover until the
end of time. Christ himself kept that
Passover, right? So when you believe in
Trinity, you're not serving the father,
you automatically
decline the Passover. The Trinity allows
you to do this. Okay. Christ where I'm
going. Now, when you go to the Matthew 7
that brought up and it tells you, how do
we know we're serving the right uh
Christ? Lawlessness
in Christianity, that's how you know
you're not serving the right because
do you agree?
If you agree with lawlessness in
Christianity, you told me to let you
round your pointlessness. I'm asking
you. I'm giving you a lawlessness of
Christianity. No, I'm turning with I
disagree. Okay. All right. So now what I
just let you took your take your point
home, right? You told me to let you do
it. Tried to You didn't. So I I tr I I
let you go. I tied it to and No, you
said that you would, but you didn't. You
literally went off the trinity and
talked about lawlessness on the
Passover. It has nothing to do with the
trinity. The same thing. Okay. So now
serving the wrong price. I let you go,
right? Did I let you go? The right
price, brother. Did I let you go? Okay.
So let me go now. Right. I'm going. Let
me go. Let me go now. Right. I I I get
what you went. All right. Now it's my
turn. Okay. So I was using your logic.
I'm going to go back to our topic on the
knowledge. We left that. I don't know
why you abandoned that. So when we
talked about the knowledge, this is how
we know that when it talks about it's
declarative knowledge with the sun in
that context. One, he's telling us
everything that's happening up leading
to that day and on that day. He tells us
exactly what's going to happen. So it
doesn't make sense that he doesn't even
know his own coming of his own day. He's
the one coming, right? And so he even
talks about No, he doesn't. He tells us
it's not for him to declare. That's what
he means by knowledge. Which means let
me vote. I'm talking about it all. So
let me finish. Let me finish. When you
talk about according to your logic,
Jesus needs to include himself in when
it talks about um it's not for you to
know the times and seasons that the
father fixed by his own authority. Jesus
doesn't include himself. So that means
he's excluded from the knowledge. Well,
then I use that same logic and you
didn't respond to this when I said,
"Okay, did Jesus include himself when he
said it's not for you to know?" He did
not. So that means So that means hold
on, hold on a second. So that means that
he's not ex That means that he's not
part of the group, if we're going by
your logic, he's not part of the group
who's not supposed to know that they are
our Now let's talk about Jesus's
knowledge. John 16:30 and 31. It says,
"Now we know that you know all things,
right? Cuz you speak plainly." So the So
Jesus So the Bible says that Jesus knows
all things in John 16:30. And you know
how he responds? He doesn't say, "Oh,
wait guys, no, stop. I told you guys I
don't know the hour." No, he says, "Do
you now believe?" Why would you say that
specifically?
Why would he say that specifically? Can
I ask you um what is Revelation 3? My
brother, can you respond to what I just
said? Just eat. What does all things
just eat? So, do can you affirm that the
Bible says Jesus knows all things? You
asked why didn't he inject there? Um,
right. That was that wasn't the question
to you. That was rhetorical. Well, my
question to you is, how do you deal with
the fact that the Bible says that Jesus
knows all things? Can you go to the
scripture? Yes. John 16:30.
He's already there. He's already there.
John 16
in me and you
and they also may be in us. John 16. I
mean that's the scripture I usually
always see. Are we now in the trinity
know that you know all things
all things and do not need anyone to
question you. This is why I believe that
you came from God. Right. Of course.
Okay. Came from God. Of course.
It doesn't say that either. No. No. So,
let's continue. Came from God. Watch
what Jesus responds. I believe that you
came from God. Jesus says, "Do you now
believe that Yahawah is coming?"
Yeah. No, you're done. Yeah. It stop. It
stopped at 31. Right. Do you now
believe? Right. So, they say, "Now we
know that you know all things and you've
come from God." He says, "Do you now
believe?" So, the contradiction to this
Christian, what are you saying? What's
your point? My point is is that with
scriptures my my point is you want you
want to answer I'm just clarifying the
question. Okay. So the point is is that
when we look at scripture when it comes
to the knowledge of Christ it's clear he
knows all things. It's it's explicit.
That's what we get. We agree there so
far. Right. Okay. Let's do Do we agree?
I'm on topic. I'm on topic. I need you
to agree or disagree with that. I
disagree doesn't know all things. So you
disagree with the scripture? No. I agree
with the scripture. So he knows all
things. I agree with these three
scriptures I presented. Wait, wait. Just
just according to the scripture. Okay.
According to the scripture, does he know
all things? I agree. So he knows all
things. No, no, no,
bro. I can't. So are you are we going to
ignore these three scriptures? No, we're
not ignoring. We're we're harmonizing.
Does he Does he know all things? When
you har all things doesn't necessarily
mean is the last day as it says here. Is
the last day one of those things? Is is
the last day something to know? You're
doing your
skill. Your skill
what does all what does all mean, bro?
What does all mean?
Insane. He doesn't know the last things.
What does what does all mean?
Just through scriptures. This is why I
went to I get what you're saying. Yes or
no? What does all mean? Knows all
things. What does the word all mean?
What does the word all mean? What do we
do with the scriptures? We read.
Reading. So what does what does all
mean? Know the last day. What does all
mean? All means all. Okay. Including the
day, right? Well, you're saying no,
excluding the day because because it
says it there. Do we ignore this? Okay.
Do we ignore that? All right. So, let's
go with your logic. So because Jesus
says no one knows neither the son and
you want to take that to mean cognitive
take it literally then that means that
when wait that means when Paul said that
he came when he came he decided to know
nothing except Jesus and cru and him
crucified that means take your logic and
your reasoning Paul didn't know his name
Paul didn't know who the Corinthians
were Paul didn't know how he got there
Paul didn't know the letters he was
writing Paul didn't know math Paul
didn't know how to spell he didn't know
where he was from. He didn't know
nothing except Jesus and him crucified.
Right. This is I I agree. I agree. You
made a made a point with the Pope. Okay.
What I'm saying is there are multiple
scriptures that doesn't support the fact
Christ is equal to the father. Like
what? Christ was created where show me
the verse. Christ was created. Yeah. I
know you're familiar with the
Colossians. And do you want to go to
Colossians 1? No. Colossians 15. No, no,
no.
Is there we could go to Colossians.
Revelations 3:14. Okay. Revelation 3:14.
He's the beginning of God's creation,
right? Unto the angel of the Lord. Uh
unto the angel, the angels of Gosians,
right? These things, says, "Amen." The
faithful and true witness, the beginning
of the creation of God. In the
beginning, he's talking about Christ.
And he refers to Christ as the beginning
of the creation of God.
Yeah. The beginning of the creation of
God. Yeah. Okay, there you go. All
right, so Christ is created. All right,
you want a response to that? Okay, so
here it is. Christ is the beginning of
the creation of God. That doesn't mean
he's created.
Now, now let me finish. Now, when he
sees you, let me finish when he sees.
Brother, I let you read the verse, man.
I let you make your point. Okay, cuz I
knew where you were going with this.
He's the beginning of the creation of
God. Means that he's the start of it.
He's the source. The word in the Greek
is ar. You know what ar you familiar
with the the word? Okay. So the word ar
literally means the source or the author
of the beginner of. So he started
creation. He's the one who created it.
Creation comes from him. Very clear. Yes
it is. Christ is the start. And that's
why you have multiple scriptures that
says the same thing. That says what?
Hebrews. Your Hebrews 1 and one, right?
You have You went to Hebrews 1. Hebrews.
Wait, wait, wait. You want to Hebrews 1.
Colossians 1:15. I know. I know you're
familiar. I I get it. So, in Hebrews
one, it says he's God who he created the
He created the times with
now
Hebrews 1. In Hebrews 1, um so many
times maners speak in the time pass unto
the fathers by the prophets as his last
spoken unto us by his son who he has
appointed here of all things by whom
also he made the words. Okay? Made the
words through him. Right? So that means
he had to exist before the worlds,
right? What does that mean? That means
he's not created.
That makes no sense. Okay, if are you
created created? Do you even know what
that word is in the in the Greek? I'm
created and have children. Do you know
what the word is in the Greek? Christ
was created to create all things. Can
you show me where it says that? That's
Look, Revelation I gave you makes it
simple. No, it doesn't. Revelation
refutes. Beginning of the creation.
Yeah, he started it. The beginning of
the creation. He started it all. That's
not what that means. Christ is the
beginning of the creation. That's what I
Can you show me where it it says that
he's created? Revelations 3:14. I just
read it to you. All right, brother.
Look, um, if if if we're at this point,
bro, let me let me just No, no, no. Cuz
you just made your point and I'm going
to respond to what you just said. I'm
going to respond to what you just said.
You just said that you went back to
Revelation 14 as if I never said
anything. It's like it went through one
ear and out the other. Do you know what
the word RK means? Yes, I know. Okay,
I'll say it again. Please pay attention
this time, bro. Okay. The word RK means
source. That word for beginning, it
means source. Author, beginning means
you're the one who starts the thing. It
comes from you. So create the creation
of God came from Jesus. We're created
through him. So he's not part of
creation. He's the creator, the one who
started it. Is that the same as
Colossians 1:15? Yes. The firstborn of
every creator. Yes. What word is that?
What word are you referring to?
Beginning or creature? Which one? Both.
Beginning is Wait, wait. I'm talking
about beginning. Beginning is now you
switched. So Colossians and this is why
I didn't want to get into this. You said
you quoted Revelation 3. Bro, I'm giving
you saying the same thing. Don't switch
verses in the middle of it when I when
we're talking about something else. I'm
giving you the same thing in Okay. So
now we're in Colossians. Why? In Hebrew
and in Revelation. Which one do you
Which one do you want to deal with?
Saying the same thing was created. Which
one do you want to deal with? Do you
want to deal with Colossians one? No.
No, no, no, no. Stop. Do you want to
deal with Colossians 1 now? No, you're
going to get I really wanted to talk to
you about brother. Do you want to deal
with Colossians 1 now? I just you just
did. You just did. Okay, go to
Colossians 1. You just did. All right.
What does it say? You're in the image of
the invisible God. Uh the firstborn of
every of every creature. For by him were
all things created. For by him what? For
by him. By him. Same thing. He made all
things. For by him he made what? How? He
made how many things? Some things or
all? All things. Did he deny denying
that? You are denying it cuz you're
saying that he was created. He was
created and he created all things.
That means that he didn't create all
things. I have it's the same thing. Do
you have children? Were you created?
Bro, how can somebody who preexist? Were
you created? How can somebody who
pre-exist? Can Can you talk to me,
brother? Talk to you. No, no, no. I
mean, he's been injecting all this time,
but it's as simple as that. We're
created, we create children. Do you
agree? Sure. That's the same concept.
Wow. Christ was created. He was given
the power to create. Where does it say
he's created there? What I just read off
in Colossians 1, where does it say he's
created? When it says he created all
things, make it make sense for me,
brother. Firstborn of every creature.
Oh, that tells you he was created. He
firstborn. Okay. Every creation. All
right. Do me this favor. Can you Can you
read verse 18?
And he's the head of the body. Uh-huh.
The church. Uhhuh. He's the beginning.
Uh-huh. The firstborn from the dead.
Wait, wait, stop there. The first born
of the what? The first born from the
dead. Is he the first one to ever die?
What you What's your What's your It says
he's the firstborn of the dead. Was he
the first one to ever die?
No. So you look, you said since he's the
first born of every creature, this means
he's the first creature. This says he's
the first born from the dead. So that
means he's the first one that ever died,
right? The beginning. It doesn't say
that. It does. Right. Who is the
beginning of what?
The first right before it says the
firstborn of the dead. He is the
beginning. Is he the first one to ever
die? He was created to create all. Is he
the first one to ever die?
No. Thank you. So firstborn doesn't mean
literal first thing. Correct. Of the
subject, right? Okay. First doesn't mean
firstborn has two meanings, brother.
Biblically, it can mean what you're
saying, right? Like you're the first
thing. It could also mean a position of
preeminence, of supremacy, right? So
right as we finish the verse, watch
finish 18. I know this is that in all
things he might have preeminence. In all
things he might have preeminence. So
he's the first notice this. He's the
firstborn of every creature and he's the
firstborn of the dead is he's not the
first one to ever die and he's not the
first thing created because he created
all things. So let me finish. This is
what you are disagreeing with this. So
this is the point. This is the point.
This is the point. You're trying to
align. Brother, you got to you got to
listen, bro. You're not listening.
You're not listening. It's just you
haven't really made me get to my point.
Okay, I'm I'm going to just say this and
we can wrap up. I'm going to say this.
We can wrap up the point. I'm saying we
can say this and wrap cuz you're not
letting me speak. No, no, this word is
we'll end it here. Yeah, we'll end it
here. I'll be quiet. No, it's okay.
We'll end it here. So, so to your point,
we just demonstrated how in context the
word firstborn will tell you how it's
being used, whether it's being used
literally as the first thing of whatever
that category is or if it's a position
of supremacy over that category. So,
when it says he's the firstborn of every
creature, it's not saying that he's the
firstborn, the first thing created. And
it tells you how in the next verse. For
by him all things were created. So that
means he can't possibly be created if he
created all things. Now hold on a
second. Firstborn from the dead. It's
not talking about him being the first
one to ever die, but that but that he's
supreme over all those who die and rise
again because he's the one who first
died and he's the first one who rose to
glorification. So he's supreme over
everyone who rises from the dead. That's
why he's the first born of the dead. So
do you agree in all three scriptures?
Revelations 3:14 as well. Do you agree?
Just hold on. Focus. Dude, you cannot
focus for the life of me. I listen.
Okay. So do you agree that contextually
firstborn of every creature is not
literal? Do you agree with that? But
it's pointing to his position of
supremacy over creation. You're saying
in all scriptures we're reading
regarding that. Is that what you're
saying? All all the script I'm asking.
Is that what you're saying? Thanks for
coming, man. Look at this. Don't do
that. Thanks for coming. Are you saying
it all with red? I appreciate I
appreciate the conversation. In every
case, is that what you're saying? Don't
leave me hanging, man. Why you don't
don't do the running thing? I'm I'm
going to run. Thanks for coming. Listen.
Lawlessness. You're right. Your
lawlessness. You're right. You're
breaking the commandments. You're
leaving me hanging, man. We We can't
leave. My main Look, when I came to you
over there, look, look, look, look,
look, look,
look. When I came to you over there, I
said, "I've got one question. Come on,
bro." I said, "I have one question." You
going to leave me hanging for real? I
said, "I have one question." Are you
really going to leave me hanging? I got
to go back to America. I know. Give me
that one question. Are you going to
leave me hanging? Just Thank you. Thanks
for coming. I'm not going to let go.
Just one. I'm done.
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.